we talked about this yesterday where
normally you don't give yourself a
nickname Muhammad Ali gave himself the
nickname of the greatest at age 22 he's
the greatest he called himself the
greatest normally somebody bestows a
nickname upon you like Wayne Gretzky he
didn't call himself the great one a
local sports writer called him the great
one Wayne Gretzky kind enough to join us
Wayne how are you this morning I'm doing
okay did you ever discuss your nickname
with Muhammad Ali uh he did with me one
time he came into the locker room in the
old LA forum and about 1983
coincidentally enough Mark Messier is
uncle Larry Messier used to be part of
his management team and corporate
marketing team so he brought him down to
the morning skate one day to meet the
players and say hello and get pictures
and he came in the locker room and he
said he was looking for the great one
because I'm not the great one because
he's the greatest of all time so we just
let him say okay that's fair that's fair
enough by me and good for you set back
in my chair and slumped in the corner
was that the first time you'd met ollie
yeah first time I met him did you you
know I think it's one of those guys that
you're not quite sure how you're going
to react when you see them until you see
him and then you know there's it's
pretty intimidating you know what it was
very intimidating and I'll tell you
because he was such a huge figure not
just in the sports world but worldwide
but I'll tell you one of the great
stories I was in the Plaza Hotel one
time in New York and I was standing a
lobbyist Gordie Howe and I thought it
was so amazing Muhammad Ali came over to
say hello to Cody how and I was standing
there thinking wow - the greatest
athletes and - the nicest people of all
time just standing or lobby of a hotel
talking and chatting and it was one of
the great sports moments for me
something I'll never ever forget but
they were both extremely personable and
you know did a lot of people who are
less fortunate everywhere when it comes
to nicknames I don't know if you ever
tried to shy away from being called the
great one I know that it it was given to
you at a young age like like Jerry West
doesn't like to be called the logo you
know the NBA logo you know he sort of
cringes when you bring that up was was
there any time you wanted to distance
yourself from that nickname oh yeah yeah
a lot of times especially when you play
poorly and you have a really bad night
and especially when you're younger so
you know it was not something I was ever
comfortable with guys lady said again in
Jon Hoeber the writers reporter gave me
that nickname and you know it's one of
those things that stuck but trust me
I much prefer when people call me Wayne
it's much simpler what was your other
nickname well I've a few my family calls
me talked friends call me grits and some
of my old teammates call me Douglas
because my middle name is Douglas I've
seen that more nicknames and I do assess
at some points here what no I doc walk
because I was chasing one day that
playing golf you know that I'm an
honorary doctor and how come nobody ever
calls and so the kids at the golf clubs
Barry called me doc so that kind of
translated into some of my friends and
some of my closer buddies and so inside
the world of our house it's I'm not a
lot of them bye doc now did you your
former teammate Dave Semenko did he
fight Ali in an exhibition
yeah it's funny because learning that's
a Marx uncle set that up and I saw on TV
the other night I saw Ali had one of
those exhibitions against Lyle Alzado
and then they showed Dave Semenko and I
called him right afterwards and I was
like David you gotta get a tape of this
this is unreal because it looked it was
almost kind of funny because now he was
playing with them
Mako's a big man a tough guy he's six
five he's 220 pounds he is a fighter
he's tough and Ali looked like he was
just playing with a little kitty cat but
you gotta get a tape of that is
something you're gonna love to have the
rest of your life
he's Wayne Gretzky the Hall of Famer
Douglas Gretzky or you can call him doc
joining us Dan Patrick show can you see
any parallels Wayne with Sidney Crosby
with pressure to win that we see with
LeBron James well listen you know I said
this before the athletes today they're
so big and strong and the equipment and
the coaching and the teaching you know
games have progressed and these athletes
today are exceptional and a champion is
always on the shoulders the same
problems LeBron pericolic Crosby it's
kind of it's like Bobby Orr the new
Messier the bigger the game the better
that they played and the more they
excelled and the more fun they had and
you can just see it in his eyes that
although it's probably very tense and
it's stressful he's having a lot of fun
playing and obviously when you up three
two one or make sure a lot more fun but
I think Cosby has played very well I
think the Penguins have played extremely
well and the other side of things you
know the Sharks are definitely not out
of it you know the best road team in
hockey and the guy won one game there
and you never know what happens if you
played today growing up today to play in
the NHL would you be a different size
would you be a different type of player
you know I don't think I could have been
I think the one thing that made me
successful is that I the things I did I
worked on and and I used them to my
advantage so I didn't have them I wasn't
the fastest skater or the hardest shot
or the strongest player but I utilized
the things that I had my work ethic and
my hockey sense and my preparation for
the game and respect for the game so I
don't think I would have changed my game
whatsoever now maybe I would have been a
little bit faster because the skates are
better today but all in all I don't
think I would have changed at all
so you would have been more physical
like you wouldn't have added you know
try to add 15 pounds
no no because first you know I wouldn't
change much at all I probably would have
played this area maybe I would have to
get bigger but you know I don't I don't
think in this day and age although size
is a factor I think speed is more
important right now than anything the
worlds are such that you know you can
hook and you can hold so it consequently
we made room for the smaller player in
the National Hockey League to play as
long as you can skate or long you're
smart you can play in the NHL most goals
you ever had in any game at any age 10
years old I got 9 goals in one games
when I was 10 years old and I got mad at
the coach because he didn't play me in
the third period talk to him for a day
how many assisted you have yeah we were
talking about the Flamingo kid the movie
that your wife was in now did you meet
did you meet Janet before she did that
movie or after she did that movie I was
in California and I did a show called
dance fever where they had celebrity
judges and Janet had been brought to
California by Merv Griffin who own the
show dance neighborhood Danny Theriot
and she is one of the group regular
girls on the show and I remember they
told me I had to dance out there and I
can't dancer I'd be the last guy ever to
go intentional the stars they have no
livin whatsoever so I had to dance out
there so actually that was the first
time we met and then about a month later
she went off to New York I think at that
point in time to film from Lingle kid
but we did meet once in 1981 yeah did
you want to beat up Matt Dillon in that
movie yeah after watching that movie
okay could you not Matt Dillon
Tomiko could've yeah I know you meant
Messier could have taken him down hey
great to talk to you as always safe
travels thanks for joining us okay any
time and nice talking to you hope your
golf game as well is but you're not
playing at Sherwood anymore where are
you playing no no I am I know you were
in st. Louis and we have events on this
week so we're going to drive down to
Memphis and take him back to his mom and
dad and watch a couple days in Memphis
before he heads off to the US Open so it
could be a fun week next week in
Pittsburgh weather maybe a parade for
the people in the US Open how are you as
a granddad my wife's a better man mom
that I am granddad but we're loving it
in life good to talk to you safe travels
till Janet we said long take care thanks
Mike the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience